okay I present to you today full
unhinged lunacy or terrible people you
can decide which it is I'm not going to
tell you which it is and this story
comes to us from Newfoundland
Pennsylvania I guess to push back
against what some churchgoers saw as an
unfair attack on assault weapons as a
result of the mass shootings where such
weapons were used worshipers in a church
held a ceremony where they wore what
looked like dollar store tiaras as well
as strange sort of cloaks or gowns and
clutched ar-15 rifles almost like you
would hold a baby and drank holy wine
and said vows to the ar-15 rifles this
is basically the closest you can come to
marrying a weapon okay and the entire
thing led to a nearby school shutting
down classes for the day dozens of ar-15
rifles were brought into the church the
religious connection was they said it
symbolizes the rod of iron from the
Christian book of Revelation and the
pastor who leads this church is Shaun
moon and if the name moon rings a bell
for you he happens to be the son of the
reverend sun myung moon now deceased who
was a self-proclaimed Messiah and
founded that cult known as the
unification Church they make this very
very real all of a sudden I've been
talking about second amendment
fetishists for years
what is more fetishization of weapons
then saying a vow to your ar-15 rifle in
a church service while clutching it like
you would a newborn baby they are doing
the equivalent of pronouncing a lifelong
commitment similar to a marriage vow to
a gun and it's indistinguishable from
Isis it's a different flavor but this is
the tally born again or the tally
Baptists call it whatever you want now
when you look at the details as if you
need to it actually gets even more
ridiculous because when they got to
church with their ar-15s an attendant
would check each weapon at the door
to make sure it was unloaded and that it
was secured with a zip tie which would
prevent it from discharging how does
that make sense right guns are great
gun-free zones are terrible this is so
important to me that I'm doing the
equivalent of marrying it through a vow
but we actually don't really trust the
worshipers with the guns so please check
your bullets at the door like every
aspect of this is a it is a self-parody
good thing that they had those zip ties
though especially because that whole
crowd is drinking wine or otherwise
you'd have a group of armed people who
are also intoxicated I don't want to
charge that and of course the wine that
they were drinking is the blood of
Christ obviously and it's like you know
I know that that's a common thing but in
the end is that any more normal than
marrying a gun like the I literal body
of Christ it's a different motive right
it's a difference oh yeah and the wafers
or the body of Christ that's a different
story probably not what we're talking
about today but what we're talking about
today is that this is what we're
fighting against right I've talked about
how if we don't have some shared set of
values that can serve as a jumping-off
point to resolve our political
differences it's very difficult to have
a productive conversation about policy
right how do you start a conversation
about gun safety with someone who
dresses up to go to church and does the
closest thing you can do to marrying a
gun right and that's why I don't
actually think you can talk to these
people these are individuals that need
to be marginalized in the political
system they need to be made irrelevant
through voter turnout because how do you
start a conversation with someone like
this we're what sort of shared value can
you have with someone who says what I
need to do as a response to the school
violence and the mass shootings and the
political discussion about guns is to
bring my rifle to church dress up with a
dollar store crown and a pink and white
smock white gloves and basically marry
my rifle right where can we start like I
just wouldn't even know I wouldn't even
know where to start and that's why I
don't think we really can talk to these
people and that voter turnout
is the way to marginalize these views to
the extent that it's even possible and
you know that this church is in
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania is a
relatively purple state which can go one
way or the other and this is what we're
fighting against it's bad